peu
[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes très heureux à la
rédaction d'antenne 2 heureux et aussi
un peu ému de pouvoir vous retrouver ce
soir comme tous les jeudis à 20h30 pour
vous présenter
envoyé spécial c'est vrai qu'il y a
longtemps que nous avions envie de vous
expliquer le monde en vous racontant des
histoires des histoires d'hommes des
histoires de femmes des histoires
parfois graves parfois plus souriante
mais des histoires toujours émouvante
est significative d'une société d'un
pays en crise ou d'un problème qui nous
concerne c'est vrai enfin que ces années
90 seront déterminantes pour tous à
l'est comme à l'ouest et qu'elles
peuvent nous réserver quelques surprises
de taille juste pour nous rappeler que
la réalité c'est souvent beaucoup plus
fort que la plus incroyable des fictions
à preuve ce premier numéro d'envoyé
spécial avec d'abord un reportage sur
saône dyke en azerbaïdjan une ville
victime d'une pollution monstrueuse une
pollution au mercure qui tue les enfants
et puis la roumanie à travers le regard
d'un cinéaste roumain en exil en france
depuis 25 ans et qui retrouve son pays
et ses racines
[Musique]
enfin le chili avec des femmes qui
dansent pour retrouver leurs maris
frères au fils disparu durant les seize
ans de régimes militaires des femmes qui
dansent avec des fantômes sung ait donc
en azerbaïdjan une ville à quelques
milles 500 km au sud de moscou une ville
créée dans les années 50 de toutes
pièces au nom du développement
industriel à tout prix sung ait
ville-symbole à plus d'un titre d'abord
parce que si nous avons pu nous rendre
là bas c'est à la faveur de la
pérestroïka cette politique d'ouverture
mise en place par mikhaïl gorbatchev qui
nous arrache des bravos lorsque l'on
assiste à la libération des peuples en
europe de l'est mais qui nous arrache
aussi parfois des cris d'horreur
lorsque l'on tente de faire un état des
lieux en union soviétique sung ait ville
symbole parce que gilles rabin et
georges en scène et ont découvert l'un
des problèmes majeurs de la terre à
l'aube de l'an 2000 la pollution
certaines scènes risque de heurter
quelques sensibilités
c'est un document
[Musique]
nous sommes en union soviétique et c'est
un bidonville
officiellement il n'existe pas on
appelle village des zecs c'est à dire
des anciens prisonniers du goulag
ce bidonville cachés sous les cheminées
d'usiné en réalité aucun ancien
prisonnier n'a jamais habité ici dans ce
bidonville vivent des ouvriers leurs
femmes et leurs enfants
né dans un bidonville de saône gates
la ville n'est du pétrole la capitale
soviétique de la chimie lourde
19 usines chimiques pour produire du
chlore du caoutchouc synthétique ou des
phosphates en passant par l'ensemble des
dérivés du pétrole de l'éthane et du
propane 19 usines autour du bidonville
des zecs en réalité une centaine
d'unités de production qui fabrique une
centaine de dérivés chimiques toxiques
des dizaines de substances toxiques sont
rejetées directement chlore fluor et
leurs dérivés hydrogène fluoride
hydrogène chloride dichloroéthane
epichlorhydrine phénol méthanol benzol
stérols et divine il l ait encore
d'autres produits toxiques que nous ne
sommes pas arrivés à identifier
précisément aujourd'hui tous les
mélanges de produits dangereux qui
cependant est prospère avec tous les
rejets vous avez cités
personne ne sait exactement on connaît
même pas les quantités exactes
bien que les statistiques officielles
soient fausses on peut affirmer que près
d'une tonne de produits chimiques est
rejetée dans la nature par an et par
habitant
comme catalyseur du chlore cet exemple
le mercure est utilisé comme catalyseur
d électrolyse pour obtenir du chlore
c'est un procédé obsolète et dangereux à
sung à près de 10 tonnes de mercure ont
été rejetées directement dans la nature
sur 17 rejets toxiques identifié à sung
ait 12 cents narcotiques comme des
drogues deux passent directement dans le
sang un au moins le mercure attaque
directement les centres nerveux eu
évidemment ne le savent pas
ouvrier depuis dix ans dans la même
usine chimique
il gagne 240 roubles par mois et il a
les moyens de payer un loyer
il a écrit partout à la mairie à l'
usine aux soviets
partout la même réponse il faut attendre
les dirigeants ne nous considère pas
comme des êtres humains
est ce qu'un être humain peut vivre ici
entrée est regardée avec nos quatre
enfants nous sommes six dans une seule
pièce
c'est insupportable on a pas d'air c'est
timide parce que nous vivons à même la
terre et les enfants sont toujours
malades aujourd'hui en dur sont comme
les huit appareils
selon les règlements tous les rejets des
usines devraient être traitées avant
d'être rejetées par ce canal dans la mer
caspienne
mais les systèmes de traitements n'ont
jamais fonctionné certains n'ont même
jamais été installés tous les rejets
toxiques s'en vont directement à la mer
conscience moi ça fait 20 ans que je
sais comme chimiste je connais les
technologies utilisées donc les roger
qui s'écoule par ici cela fait 20 ans
qu'on refuse de m'écouter c'est
seulement depuis un an grâce à la
glasnost qu'on en parle plus ouvertement
évidemment à mon avis et je peux le
prouver il n'y a pas d'enfant en bonne
santé à sung ait une tonne de produits
toxiques rejetée par an et par habitant
deux cent mille habitants 200 mille
tonnes tsonga était la capitale
soviétique de la mortalité infantile
un enfant sur trois meurent à la
naissance à l'écart de la ville les
enfants un cimetière à part ces trois
tombe là sont toutes fraîches et celle
là aussi
docteur zafar coulibaly martyrs des
enfants de soundbite c'est sa croisade
depuis 20 ans par jour de jeu
pour découvrir cet hôpital il faut
quitter la ville il est financé par la
municipalité mais aussi par les budgets
sociaux des 19 complexe chimique hôpital
auspices plutôt l'hospice des enfants
débiles de son kite débile léger débiles
profonds vivent ici mélanger tous
enfants des bidonvilles
vieux réflexe on ne veut pas qu'il soit
filmé il est né les jambes paralysées
il a 25 ans
[Musique]
vous n'allez quand même pas les laisser
le film et lui et pourquoi tu as honte
tu n'as pas avoir honte
est ce que nos dirigeants n'ont jamais
eu honte hum ça suffit on ne va pas
passer notre vie à tout camouflé atout
caché laisser le passé devant la caméra
ok
[Musique]
ils ont tous les muscles atrophiés
basandella certaines choses intéressante
a dit il ya ceux qui parlent mais il
peut passer par le policier chez hsbc à
chauny si un musulman
il ya des jeux qui ont 5 ans 6 ans 10
ans 15 ans dix ans celui là je le
connais bien il a dix ans ces enfants
ont été abandonnés par leur famille le
plus souvent dès la naissance
[Musique]
il n'arrive pas à dormir malgré les
médicaments qu'on leur a donné
ici se trouvent les paraplégiques
je vais vous les présenter ici vous avez
trois soeurs là deux soeurs et leurs
frères ce sont des familles entières qui
sont touchés ne devez jamais cet enfant
là aussi le chlore lui a brûlé les
poumons le mercure en a fait sept
enfants monstre il est né dans le
bidonville des zecs et il a quatre ans
[Musique]
ils sont directement victimes de la
pollution chimique explique le médecin
des enfants de sung ait la preuve cette
statistique qu'il est établi lui même
sur 20 ans l'endroit où ils sont nés les
rejets toxiques enregistré les taux de
mortalité infantile et de malformations
physiques et psychiques
[Musique]
ceux qui peuvent marcher le médecin
demandait qu on les rassemble dans la
salle du réfectoire
[Musique]
ces enfants qu'ils saluent comme des
adultes normaux le docteur jah fakoly f
les soigne depuis 20 ans va tant de rage
et d'impuissance 20 ans à prendre la
mesure des dégâts et du cynisme des
dirigeants politiques
le résultat du désastre écologique est
devant vous monsieur à son gheit sur
trois enfants un meurent à la naissance
le deuxième enfant meurt avant cinq ans
une fois sur deux le troisième souffre
de balle formation ou de maladie
chronique grave
une fois sur deux ce qui se passe ici
monsieur c'est un génocide un génocide
chimiques
[Musique]
gilles rabin la première question qu'on
se pose c'est comment vous avez pu
filmer cette histoire est bien j'avais
déjà entendu parler de cette histoire
mais j'avais pas pu la filmer
nous étions déjà les assauts gates l'an
dernier et les autorités nous avait
imposé un guide qui était le secrétaire
à l'idéologie du pc local comme attaché
de presse et pas vraiment l'idéal à
cette fois ci grâce à la montée de la
revendication nationaliste et au
désordre tout simplement que ça provoque
de la république nous avons pu
rencontrer ce médecin le docteur coup
liège et nous avons pu filmer l'envers
du décor ce mythique enfin en tout cas
une partie de langage du corps justement
est-ce que soun grecque est un cas isolé
en union soviétique
pas du tout si on faisait si on voulait
faire le hit parade des villes les plus
polluées du rss entourait ce gars est
bien sûr montrent eux aussi astrakan on
trouverait denning grade
on trouverait des villes baltes on
trouverait où fut tourné ou fois par
exemple ou face est une ville de l'oural
qui est si pollué que même la pravda
l'organe officiel du parti communiste a
été obligé de reconnaître l'an dernier
que cette ville aurait dû être déclarée
impropre la vie humaine
à l'époque avait un million de personnes
kabila et bien aujourd'hui a toujours un
million de personnes
dernière question gilles c azéri
victimes de la pollution
les auteurs des pogroms anti arméniens
ce sont les mêmes les mêmes à la fois
victimes et bourreaux
ça c'est la question qu avec janssen le
caméraman ans s'est posé tous les jours
à soupe gheit sans répondre là pas de
réponse ainsi j'ai la roumanie
je sais vous avez déjà tout vu mais
justement ce que nous vous proposons ce
soir c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
inédit depuis 25 ans un homme un roumain
vivait en exil à paris
il s'appelle paul barbanègre à et il est
cinéaste nous lui avons demandé de
retourner pour la première fois dans son
pays de partir avec une équipe d'antenne
2 dirigée par jean louis goût serre et
de faire un film un film sur ses
retrouvailles avec sa terre avec son
peuple sur ses joies ses peines et ses
regrets c'est ce reportage que vous
allez voir un reportage à la première
personne c'est à dire le contraire de
tout ce que vous avez l'habitude de voir
dans une émission d'information
mais quelque chose auquel nous tenons a
envoyé spécial c'est à dire permettre
chaque fois que cela sera possible
un homme de fiction un homme de théâtre
ou de cinéma de se confronter au réel
ce soir donc paul barba negra retour
d'exil
en roumanie
[Musique]
le bouledogue de l'église métropolitaine
de bucarest fait vibrer dans ma mémoire
le souvenir de ses 25 années vécu en
exil à paris sous le signe de la liberté
mais sous le poids de yalta
[Musique]
voilà 25 ans quand on se salue entre
amis avec une ironie amère l'année
prochaine à bucarest
[Musique]
pour gagner la liberté j'avais perdu ma
patrie et ses souffrances rendait
d'autant plus présent le drame de ceux
qui restaient là bas exilé à l'intérieur
de leur propre pays
[Musique]
là bas les images de lénine père de la
révolution et de son émule ceausescu
haranguer actuellement les foules mais
ces multitudes ne courait pas au combat
chaque jour elle se bousculer à la
recherche de leur maigre pitance un
cabas à la main comme les esclaves d'une
utopie régi par une vision irréalisable
le marxisme véritable théorie du
sous-marin à voile
dans mes rêves je me voyais revenir sur
la tourelle du char comme combattant
d'une guerre de libération
mais les facéties de l'histoire m'ont
fait trouver le char déjà installé sur
la place du comité central et c'est mon
frère cadet l'acteur et ankara m qui
était dessus chez nous en roumanie et la
malédiction des haltes a été congelé par
une véritable croisade des enfants
cette ombre fraîche en témoigne ils sont
tombés pour leur liberté mais aussi pour
la mienne et en regardant le visage de
ces jeunes morts
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de me demander
pourquoi lui et pas moi en quoi elle est
pas ma mère
[Musique]
la flamme des sacrifices est clair la
renaissance de mon peuple
cette renaissance est aussi la mienne
d'autant plus aujourd'hui fête de
l'épiphanie
je reçois les gouttes d'eau béni commune
nouveau batel notre vie recommence au
sein de notre église
même si parmi ses hauts prélats certains
ont été indigne de leur mission
[Musique]
léger il existe un lien indissoluble
entre le sacrifice de la croix et la
résurrection
c'est ainsi que cette accompli la
résurrection de notre peuple par le
sacrifice de ses enfants et de ses
jeunes réveillé en fin de l'interminable
cauchemar ceausescu mon peuple commence
à entrevoir l'avenir comme un coin de
ciel bleu à la place des armes aurait
arraché
aujourd'hui grâce à ce miracle c'est un
miracle
et dieu nous a nous a fait vivre à
travers une jeunesse absolument
sensationnel qui est sorti devant les
chars bandai est tous à la poitrine nue
c'est la naissance de la roumanie
contemporaine
donc je l'espère du moins tout le monde
si je suis demandée partout dans le
monde qui se font ces roumains comment
ils puissent subir sans réagir
on peut pas réagir dans un vaste étang
de concentration dont les dimensions
sont celle de bay dans ce goulag
l'église a été notre rempart spirituelle
comme toujours dans l'histoire de notre
peuple
mon rêve pour ceux de ma génération vous
était l'une des figures les plus
lumineuses de l'église
je voudrais donc vous demander comment
jugez vous que l'église a traversé ces
épreuves qui ont duré plus de 40 ans
car à droite patrick cherdel pendant ces
années l'église incarnée par sa doctrine
l'opposition à la dictature y ait un
vrai dire elle était la seule opposition
entier si la dictature prenait le
matérialisme nous nous témoignons pour
l'univers spirituel des chrétiens
si la dictature était ouvertement athée
nous nous avons toujours à portée et le
témoignage vivant de dieu ou des sas
entre la pression la plus forte était
surtout sensibles à travers la
restriction en action missionnaire de
l'église qui était perçu comme un danger
il ne faut pas oublier que l'église
orthodoxe a été pendant des années la
seule privé de catéchèse
[Musique]
l'interdiction de l'enseignement
religieux les est partie d'une vaste
conspiration du pouvoir marxiste contre
l'identité et la mémoire de notre peuple
incarnée par les églises rescapés et
surtout par les villages riche en
traditions paysannes comme ici à
mi-régime sous prétexte de la
restructuration rural le régime de
ceausescu ce n'est plus au village
pourquoi parce que le village roumain
représentent les racines même de notre
nation qui nourrissent et ce qui en
somme être ainsi des communes entières
ont été anéantis et leurs habitants
entassés dans des véritables taudis
collectif ruine et humilié les
villageois ont subi même la profanation
des tombes de leurs ancêtres déplacés de
force dans de nouveau semé diarra coups
de pelleteuse
aujourd'hui ces paysans sont devenus
étrangers dans leurs villages ils se
retrouvent locataires des taudis hlm
qui après avoir vécu dans notre village
dans la maison de nos ancêtres nous
sommes devenus simple locataire
nous espérons que c'en est fini de tout
ça fini ces amas de gravats qu'on nous
laisse vivre dans nos chaumières on est
capable de les re bâtir comme il se doit
il faut désormais laisser vivre les
paysans et les ouvriers de la ville
pourront eux aussi manger à leur faim
ils nous ont déménagé de force
c'est indescriptible si on ne voulait
pas s'en aller il vous faisait tomber le
toit sur la tête ils venaient avec leur
bulldozer il vous enfouissait sous la
maison
[Musique]
je suis dans une situation pas fameuse
parce qu'ils mentent déracinés
t'arracher de mon terroir le village
mais à une les ch'tis ils sont venus me
signifier que j'avais dix jours pour
déménager dans la prison de ceausescu
là où j'habite actuellement
[Musique]
voilà les prisons de chaouchi c'est
clapiers de béton qui ont remplacé pour
des milliers de familles l'univers de la
maison patriarcal 7 collectivisation de
l'habitat a été le second coup mortel
porté aux paysans après la
collectivisation de leurs terres
on ose à peine demandée leurs sentiments
au nouveau locataire nous vivons très
mal dans nos nouveaux appartements parce
qu'ils n'ont aucun confort il nous avait
promis du chauffage de meilleures
conditions
rien de tout ça les gens gros lot
ils dorment tout habillé quand ils ne
vont pas couché chez des amis pour
pouvoir sortir de l'hiver
[Musique]
avery melikian nous avons sept enfants
les miliciens sont venus avec leurs
fusils pour nous fourrer dans une hlm
venez chez moi il ya du givre sur les
murs les gosses passe la journée sous
les couvertures
je n'ai pas de bois de chauffage je n'ai
rien et je dors tout habillé
[Musique]
pourquoi ceausescu at il décidé
d'entasser les paysans dans ces
immeubles
j'ai longtemps réfléchi à ce projet de
systématisation des communes en fait un
programme de destruction du village
roumain de tarissement des sources
culturelles du peuple roumain et j'en
suis arrivé à la conclusion qu'il
s'agissait en fait une stratégie
diabolique pour contrôler le peuple vous
voyez on pouvait entassés un village
entier en dix immeubles les forces de
répression parfaitement aguerris pouvait
tout contrôle et toute la situation sans
jardin et personne ne pouvait se cacher
à
j'ai vécu mon retour au pays libéré sous
le signe de la renaissance nationale et
de l'épiphanie le départ de bucarest
vers la france ma deuxième patrie a eu
lieu vendredi
le premier vendredi de deuil national
[Musique]
chacune des milliers de quoi qui veille
sur les tombes a acquis dans nos âmes
les proportions d'un monument national
[Musique]
nos martyrs sont morts sous le signe de
la victoire
nous offrons ainsi la liberté
[Musique]
les morts sont les héros de notre peuple
premier peuple à vaincre enfin une
dictature marxiste et a dévoilé ainsi au
monde les crimes de l'utopie marxiste
léniniste
[Musique]
ce vendredi là peut-être pour la
première fois depuis le début de la
révolution
leur enthousiasme allait se transformer
en haine brûlant les cartes deux parties
preuve de nos confusion et de nos
lâchetés
en quittant la roumanie et en regardant
cette souffrance transformée en haine
j'ai eu peur la dernière pensée ira vers
mes compatriotes en leur rappelant la
dernière phrase de michel volnay through
notre grand philosophe mort en prison
dit à ceux qui vont venir
après nous de ne pas nous venger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour le barda negra vous rentrez de
bucarest
vous vivez en france depuis 25 ans en
exil qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant restez avec nous ou en train
en roumanie le sans doute je dois
partager ma vie ce qui me reste à vivre
entre la france et la roumanie dans le
sens de partager ma vie entre paris et
les carpates
parce que je me sens tâche et surtout à
cette racine paysanne et je voudrais
vivre parmi mes roumains mais en ayant
toujours la certitude que ce que je suis
et ce que j'ai réussi à faire et
enrichir dans nos existences
j'ai obtenu ici à paris en france
est ce que j'ai réussi à structurer en
moi à travers la culture la générosité
française m'oblige à ne pouvoir pas
oublier meurent ombre parce que je dois
reconnaître qu'après vingt cinq années
d'exil je commence à ressentir galles
home
merci paul je vous dise en début
d'émission que 1990 risquer de nous
réserver quelques surprises
tout ce que l'on peut constater c'est
que 1989 nous en a produit une de taille
l'effondrement des systèmes totalitaires
à l'est comme à l'ouest
parce que pendant qu'elle est le mur
s'effondrait entre les deux allemagnes
que la tchécoslovaquie où la hongrie se
libérer un homme à l'ouest accepté de
quitter le pouvoir après 16 ans de
dictature je veux parler du chili et du
général pinochet
il ya tout juste un mois patricio aylwin
était élu président du chili héritant du
même ou d'un problème dramatique celui
des disparus le reportage que vous allez
voir et que nous avons réalisé avec
pascal stelletta raconte donc l'histoire
d'un groupe de femmes à la recherche de
leurs parents
évanoui dans la nuit de la dictature
des femmes qui se battent avec leur
coeur et leur culture avec le chant et
avec la danse
et il va nationale était sur le départ
la malle des villas construites le 13
août 1974 le matin des gens de la dina
la police politique sont arrivés chez
nous pour arrêter mon frère ils se sont
fait passer pour des collègues de
travail
et comme mon frère n'était pas là ils
sont ressortis et ont commencé à
surveiller la maison lorsque mon frère
est arrivé dans l'après-midi ma mère
était tout seul
ils ont encerclé la maison puis ils sont
entrés là ils ont pris mon frère et
l'ont emmené dans l'une de leurs prisons
secrètes la prison numéro 38 et ce n'est
que plus tard que nous avons appris
qu'ils l'avaient torturé
il est vrai qu'à ce moment là mon frère
était très exposée il était membre d'une
organisation d'extrême gauche et ancien
officier de l'armée
qu'est ce que vous avez fait à ce moment
là nous avons commencé les recherches
dans les différents camps de
concentration dans les commissariats à
la morgue dans les hôpitaux
malheureusement comme il n'y avait aucun
témoigne son incarcération
personne n'a pu nous répondre
[Applaudissements]
voici quinze ans que chaque matin à la
même heure
violetta quitte la petite maison qu'elle
partage avec sa soeur 15 ans passés à se
battre avec la même détermination
au point que sa vie toute entière se
confond aujourd'hui avec son combat
mieux que serait sa vie sans cette lutte
quotidienne cette recherche inlassable
de la vérité et de quoi serait fait ces
jours s'il n'était alimenté par l'espoir
de savoir l'espoir de faire payer un
jour les coupables nos à l'impôt ni date
10 les murs non à l'impunité
violetta habite dans la banlieue de
santiago
et c'est en autobus qu'elle gagne le
centre de la capitale
une heure de transport pour faire le
point de ses activités
celles qui sont passées et celles à
venir avant d'arriver à la vie cali
la vie cali c'est à dire l'évêché de san
diego un mot magique pour toutes les
victimes de la dictature qui pendant 16
ans ont trouvé ici réconfort et chaleur
mais aussi entraide et efficacité c'est
ici que violetta rencontrer d'autres
femmes comme elle à la recherche de
leurs parents disparus
c'est ici qu'elle ont eu l'idée de
renforcer leur combat en faisant appel à
leur culture et leurs traditions
en utilisant la danse et le chant
[Musique]
je suis la mère d'alfredo leur race
castagnède a détenu disparu le 4 mars
je suis les pousses de total que
possible et david hess détenus et
disparus le 21 septembre 1973
je suis la mère de miguel ángel pizarro
à manille colis détenus et disparus le
19 novembre 1974
je suis la soeur de milton morales à
aveda détenus et disparus le 13 août
je suis la cousine de maria thales jerez
détenus et disparus le 27 septembre 1973
je suis l'épousé ou fallico dana et les
cortès détenus et disparus le 5 mai 1976
je suis la soeur de mon père torres
allavena détenus et disparus le 13
octobre 1973
je suis la fille de victor dias lopez
détenus et disparus
le 12 mai 1976
il allait
[Musique]
il a
il a dit
[Musique]
au fil du temps
il
nenê
c'est l'été
[Musique]
m
emmenés par viollet à elles sont une
quinzaine sur l'alameda la grande avenue
de san diego une quinzaine de femmes qui
bravent les derniers jours de la
dictature militaire pour dénoncer la
torture et la disparition de leurs
parents
la scène ne prendra pas plus de deux
minutes le temps de coller sur les murs
leurs affiches de se nettoyer les mains
et elles vont partir très vite pour
éviter les carabiniers et surtout la
prison où elles ont déjà passé trop de
jours on passe devant les murs en
regardant mais sans s'arrêter parce que
la peur existe encore au chili et puis
au bout d'un quart d'heure
ce qu'ont fait les militaires ici c'est
plus qu'un crime c'est de la stupidité
son sali les mains
au père mais vous savez personne est
intervenu contre ce type parce qu'on ne
sait pas s'il est de la police secrète
m
[Musique]
elles sont arrivées en avance trop émus
par l'invitation que leur ont adressé
les étudiants de l'université de
santiago l'un des rares foyer constant
d'opposition durant les seize ans de la
dictature militaire
elles sont émus par ce qu'elles vont
parler chanter et danser pour des jeunes
qui ont à peu près l'âge du coup d'état
qui n'ont donc pas connu l'unité
populaire de salvador allende en fait
des jeunes qui ressemble beaucoup à leur
fils frère ou mari disparu ce qu'elle
dise ce qu'elle chante c'est leur
désespoir
je t'ai cherché partout je suis allé
dans tant de rue j'ai frappé à tant de
portes mais personne n'a voulu m'écouter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il expose dès qu'il ne sait rien après
15 ans de recherche y avait toujours
l'espoir de retrouver votre frère bien
sûr je n'ai pas perdu cet espoir et je
ne le perdrai jamais parce que vous
savez le doute soit eu plus que la
vérité
nous croyons en tout cas moi
personnellement je pense que sa saison
était torturé comme on le dit il faut
peut-être mieux pour eux d'être mort
très vite mais ce sont des êtres humains
pour lesquels il faut demander la vérité
la justice et quel que soit le nombre
d'années qui passe je vais continuer à
demander ce qui est arrivé à mon frère
parce qu'on ne peut pas effacer pas 15
ans d'un seul coup de plume beaucoup de
choses se sont déroulées au chili
pendant ses 15 ans et nous n'avons
toujours aucune réponse
[Musique]
il allait l'habitacle est la clé
la phase aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme chaque semaine elles se sont
retrouvées pour parler pour broder parce
que comme pour le chant et la danse
elles ont eu l'idée d'utiliser la
tapisserie pour raconter leur histoire
et leur combat mais l'atelier de
tapisserie
c'est aussi pour ces femmes l'occasion
de faire le bilan de la semaine écoulée
et de discuter des changements en cours
au chili nous pensons qu'avec sa
démocratie qui s'installe au chili il y
a un engagement qu'a pris monsieur
aylwin le nouveau président celui de
rechercher la vérité et de faire justice
s'il tient cet engagement il n'y aura
pas de problème sinon nous allons
continuer notre lutte
descendre dans la rue chanter danser
pour obtenir la vérité et la justice
ce jour là elle avait décidé de
rejoindre la plus grande manifestation
jamais organisée au chili en l'honneur
précisément de patricio aylwin elle
avait tenu à être là pour célébrer le
retour de la démocratie
surtout pour qu'on ne les oublie pas
pour rappeler inlassablement les crimes
commis durant la dictature militaire
pour demander justice
c'est presque naturellement
la foule s'est écarté pour leur laisser
le passage manifestants sont restés par
des applaudissements mais aussi parfois
par des lames
[Applaudissements]
les noces
[Musique]
il y avait ce jour-là un million de
personnes aux parcours higgins de
santiago
[Musique]
voilà fin de ce premier numéro d'envoyé
spécial avec peut-être des sujets un peu
grave ce soit actualité oblige à jeudi
prochain donc 20h30 avec pour nous cette
même volonté montrer et expliquer pour
mieux comprendre
bonsoir
[Musique]